[Music]
this could be my last chance
ah
you can
moment of truth
yes
shouldn't be down here
i can be wherever i want nurse
it's doctor actually
you're still the help just like me
get out
michael
don't shoot
step back
what's up
put that gun
[Music]
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] is that thing
hmm
[Music]
oh god
good
do you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure we have to push the
boundaries take the risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it
are
now
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months when you're a stranger
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of you
who wants to hunt
and consume blood
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
the other half wants to control you hey
doctor mike you and i should stay in
touch
i'd do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
[Music]
you